a new real-life iPhone 15 Pro casting
has finally leaked given us the closest
look at the iPhone 15 experience yet and
even better the most detailed 15 Pro
renders were released over the weekend
so what I'm going to do in this video is
dig deep into every little detail and
finish off with some brand new major
leaks for the entire lineup That might
just make you consider a different model
later this year so let's jump right into
it just this morning on the Chinese
version of tick tock the new 15 Pro
dummy casting was revealed and it
honestly looks different than what I
expected you can watch the video right
here let's do it right now look at that
it looks absolutely beautiful and oh my
goodness did you see that camera bum
let's pause it right there there it is
the massive 15 Pro Camera bump people
thought that Apple was already crazy for
the 14 Pros camera bump that is even
bigger the whole square glass cutout is
bigger every single camera bump
separately is bigger and wider and
deeper as well just look at it from that
angle right there it sticks out almost
as much as the actual thickness of the
phone itself now the really interesting
thing that I'm noticing here is that if
you look really closely right at the top
you can see the redesigned edge of the
iPhone where it curves into the glass
and honestly I thought there would be
more of a curve compared to what I'm
seeing right now it almost looks like
the 14 pro until you notice that curve
right there on the edge and then now
looking at the bottom you can see the
new USBC Port you got that more rounded
larger shape of that Port We have
basically the same layout for the
speaker grilles right there on the
bottom and I will show you some brand
new renders from Ian zelbo that show
really close-up detail right here on the
front of course we see the dynamic
island is going to be sticking around
once again but look here on the side
there you go that is the new fully
Unison volume rocker instead of having
two separate pieces like we've had for
years on the iPhone we now have one
uniform piece which is going to be
really interesting and of course we made
videos talking about how the haptics are
gonna work there's actually going to be
a haptic motor built right behind that
volume rocker that'll make it feel like
a physical click but it's not actually a
physical button of course we have a good
look at the action button the new one
that is fully replacing the mute switch
yes after 16 years of having a mute
switch since the original iPhone it is
now going away so that looks great but
there you go that is a beautiful new
iPhone 15 Pro and to be honest it looks
a lot more similar to the current model
than I thought the redesign would be
which is a little bit disappointing but
I think it still looks good and now
let's get into Ian zabo's renders that
he released over the weekend these are
by far the most close up that I've ever
seen just take a look at this we have
the new titanium frame in this kind of
space black titanium finish but if you
look really closely you can see how the
glass on the front is no longer flat it
now curves into the edge of that
titanium frame right here in these
images you can see a close-up from the
side of the camera bump and of course it
is absolutely massive but the detail
that I notice is that the actual black
lens part is so much longer than it was
before previously you would have this
extra metal casing around it as you can
see in this image right here where you
have the entire lens broken up into
different parts this black lens part is
so much longer than before and he gives
a really good look at the new volume
rocker and the new action button right
there on the side I'm so excited to see
how that's going to work I think it's
going to be fully programmable and then
now right here at the bottom we get a
full close-up of the brand new USBC Port
but the one thing you'll notice if you
look really closely there's these really
nice lines that that go around the port
itself so it's going to be metal very
very high quality and then the one thing
I noticed in this render right here is
the insanely thin bezels apparently the
iPhone 15 Pro will have the thinnest
bezels of any phone ever not just any
iPhone any phone ever
1.55 millimeters that is the difference
we can expect on the new 15 Pro it's
just gonna make it a much more immersive
experience even though we have the
dynamic Island which is annoying the
bezels being that thin will be
incredible but the one thing that I'm
personally excited for is the brand new
color which is this deep red and
apparently they even have the color code
410d0d that looks awesome and I'm
definitely buying that model later this
year now of course those renders came
from Ian's elbow so definitely follow
him on Twitter because he does an
amazing job and if you're wondering how
he got those to be be so detailed well
last month unknowns 21 posted a real
image of the iPhone 15 Pro right here
the bottom and you can see all those
circular details that Ian added into his
renders they're directly from unknowns
21 and this leaked image and of course
you could see that texture of the
titanium and he confirmed it himself yes
it is titanium so that is amazing and
then for all the other missing pieces we
also had the exclusive case renders from
Max Weinbach that showed the exact
renders showing off the new redesigned
curve the camera bumps everything else
is directly from Max winebox so that's
how we were able to get those amazing
renders but then we got some brand new
leaks over the weekend from shrimp Apple
Pro confirming a bunch of other details
you can see right here how big the
camera bump is going to be you can see
the volume rocker right there you can
see the insanely thin bezels of course
we have the USBC Port just like from
unknowns 21 and Ian zelbo and a look at
how this volume rocker and button is
going to look just like Ian showed off
so everything is really nice and
accurate and now we even have
measurements for everything the length
with thickness the camera bump thickness
from the back glass to the camera lens
which is absolutely insane 3.78
millimeters everything is revealed right
here from shrimp Apple Pro including the
dynamic Island being the same as it was
last year and thankfully the earpiece is
getting even thinner and more refined
this time around which is another
welcome upgrade and this right here
shrimp Apple Pro shared of the new
action button and volume rocker looks
awesome and yes it is going to be solid
state and he even showed this
interesting piece off with this weird
object sitting on top of it and I wonder
if this is meant for the case
manufacturers to know kind of how to
integrate their cases to make the
features work and yes that's exactly
what shrimp said he said that this is
likely conductive padding for the
buttons that will be fused in the phone
case and will help it receive the full
gesture and actions slash sensitivity
support as other rumors have previously
mentioned that's how the capacitive
buttons will continue to work with cases
but here is the Banger that shrimp Alpha
Pro just gave us apparently the regular
iPhone 15 and 15 plus models will still
have the solid state buttons yes they
will no longer be physical buttons they
will be solid state but they're going to
be split into two different buttons like
we currently have right now instead of
the one conjoined long button that will
be exclusive for the Pro Models and the
other thing is that the regular models
will have the mute switch just like they
had before the action button will be
exclusive to the new Pro Models now
moving forward we just got another leak
this morning saying that all four of the
iPhone 15 OLED screens will use the
latest best materials which is
apparently the M12 materials which will
be kind of like the highest end giving
us the best and highest quality in terms
of the display however I do want to
mention that only the Pro Models will be
using
ltpo OLED displays which allows them to
have variable refresh rates and that
confirms that only the Pro Models will
have 120 hertz Pro motion the regular
models will still have 60hz displays
which means that for me they are
unacceptable I have to have promotion
now that I've gotten used to it and it's
just such a big deal for me and the
worst news is that that according to
Ross young he says that the regular
iPhone models will continue to get ltps
displays with only 60 hertz refresh rate
until the iPhone 17 regular model that's
when it's getting promotion that is a
very long time so if you haven't already
made the switch to the pro model do it
because it's a big difference and the
last thing that we have is an iOS 17
leak showing that we're going to be
getting a new redesigned control center
for the first time since iOS 11 so I'm
excited for that because we've had that
for a long time and I want some changes
with better features as well so
hopefully you enjoyed this video with
those new dummy casting models showing
off what it's going to be looking like
and those really close render details so
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below click the circle
box to subscribe for more videos like
this one check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
foreign